Raymond is next in Puerto Rico hi
Raymond how are you hi bream hi day I'm
closin I'm so nervous
okay brother we've never lost a patient
what's up well I just can't see a way
through at all no no light in the tunnel
nothing at all am i all almost like a
hundred grand in credit card debt Wow
would you buy I I opened my my little
like a repair cell phone repair shop
here but after the hurricane I've used
so much debt even to buy a home after my
first mortgage was first home was
flooded with the hurricane Maria and I
used a lot of credit card for the down
payment repairs on another house that
first home I I still haven't paid paid
it off and I owe that mortgage unlike 12
months behind I just don't know what to
do it was considering bankruptcy but III
don't hear any of your videos or shows
and you know ever recommending
bankruptcy so I really need advice so
what are you doing for a living now
we're repairing cell phones in a small
shop me and my wife we work together six
days a week 40 plus hours but and what I
earn here is I just can't pay paid my
mind that what do you earn any card
what are you earning well and before
tell what's your cell phone yeah what's
your so what's your cell phone business
making before taxes and before taxes and
everything like like maybe between 45
and 50 thousand dollars a year yeah and
you that are you talking about before
business expenses or before taxes before
yeah and before taxes after after I take
out like most of the expenses of the
cost of the merchandise and everything
and that's what I have and then from
there I have to pay like my my ranch
and all my other expenses your rent on
the business yeah of the shop okay what
did you do before this I was a phone
interpreter and what kind of money did
you make doing that no that was like a
725 an hour okay all right I'll tell you
what I'm gonna put you on hold I'm gonna
talk to you after this break and see if
we can walk you through some of this
back to Raymond in Puerto Rico he's got
a cell phone repair shop in Puerto Rico
and made forty five thousand last year
last couple of years and he has a
hundred thousand dollars in credit card
debt and they're just struggling having
trouble making it and that's about how
far we got in the discussion does that
sound right what you told me so far sir
correct correct I forgot to mention that
I'm behind on all of my payments of
credit card I haven't paid him in like
almost a year or or the first mortgage
so that's why I feel like I'm so deep in
trouble and I've not been able to me how
much is your first mortgage payment
hey 550 okay all right and it sounds to
me like that you're making $45,000 gross
revenue in the cell phone shop minus the
expenses of operating the business which
includes the rent on the shop is that
right yes it is okay so it sounds like
you're making under $20,000 a year
probably household income actual taxable
income you file federal income taxes in
the US right yes yes okay what did you
fight what was your taxable income last
year like like 20 yeah that's what I was
guessing okay all right and so more than
anything what you have is an income
problem don't you yes you're not making
any money both of you are working in the
shop and both of you together
working a lot hours or making $20,000 a
year curry
plus I have a vehicle that I'm also
paying
like 26,000 okay I would sell that I can
tell you that in a heartbeat
that's insanity in this situation I have
a car that costs more than you make in a
year
that's just insanity
so now let's back up and do a couple of
things so the first thing is crisis
management okay when you've got all this
stuff flying at you the stress gets very
very high the worry gets high the
hopelessness gets there and it can
affect your marriage
don't let it do that if it has already
then you all work on that you have to
protect your marriage from the stress
the number one cause of divorce in North
America is is money problems and money
stress and so you've got to manage that
then when we're coaching someone in our
offices or in one of our coaches offices
around the nation if we tell them the
very first thing they have to do is take
care of their four walls which is food
water and electricity shelter and basic
transportation this car is gone you got
to sell it but basic transportation an
inexpensive thousand dollar car that
kind of a thing and paying your mortgage
and paying your lights and your water
and buying food happens before anything
else happens everything else can sit
okay if these credit-card companies were
to sue you there's almost nothing that
they could get so I'm not worried about
them today
in the middle of crisis management
crisis management is I want to protect
you your marriage give you a place to
live and eat and have lights and water
that's the four walls of necessities
then we work on cleaning up at that our
unsecured like credit card debt or
what's left over after the sale of this
car or whatever but you can't keep this
car you understand that right yes yes I
do okay yeah I know what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do to get your income
up dramatically because I'm not shaming
you but you're you guys just aren't
make enough money man this is killing
you I know you spend more than a year
that I can't sleep well yeah okay so
what are we gonna do to get your house
what did your wife do before she worked
in a cell phone shop and she used to
work for another phone store and so we
decided like to open our own business
mm-hmm it's not going well nobody
we're both college dropouts you know I
don't have the business is not going
well there can be a lot of reasons but
you can't say oh that means but I can't
do anything else yeah you could do a lot
of other things that both of you made
20,000 okay $8 an hour 45 dollars 45
hours a week each of you would double
your all's income okay so I'm not
suggesting we close the store but one of
you needs to develop a career path
outside of the store because the store's
not making it right now it's a bad
part-time job right now and we have two
full-time people working at it yeah in
terms of the income that it's producing
that's what's killing you sir and again
I'm not picking on you I'm not trying to
kill your dream but your dream of being
a small business owner has turned into a
nightmare and so we've got to get that
is there anything we can do at the store
to increase its sales dramatically or
are you all doing about all you can do
yeah I've tried in incorporating you
know likes and computers and bringing
other devices from major brands to sell
and I haven't seen any any advanced at
all okay any improvement at all I'm
trying to repair other things that I
used to not repair and do I don't see it
anything any different okay are there
any companies after the hurricane and
the rebuilding I know you guys were hit
so hard with that hurricane and it was
really devastating to the whole island
are there any companies of size that are
hiring technology people to you know to
do computer repairs install computers
for
big company and they do it like I've got
three or I think I've got five guys here
on our team that do nothing but fix our
broken computers and install new ones
all day long okay and they make a lot
lower yeah but I mean if there's a
company in in Puerto Rico that I mean
are you in San Juan yeah I am oh okay I
don't know this I don't know the size of
that particular economy but all I'm
trying to do is just to think with you
hear from some career options or income
options because anything you could do to
get some income coming in is going to
help you a bunch to at least get those
four walls covered because right now the
car is killing you the house is killing
you and those are part of the four walls
we gotta get the car sold and we gotta
get this house caught up and you're
behind a year on it you need five
thousand dollars to catch it up yeah
yeah and that's your first goal before
you do anything else get your house
caught up and stop the foreclosure and
then keep your house current but no
matter what happens don't let your house
can ever get behind again and then you
know keep your lights and water current
never be behind a dime again you make
enough to do that and eat but you don't
make enough to pay a payment on a twenty
six thousand dollar car and you don't
make enough to address the hundred
thousand dollars or the credit card debt
and you don't make enough to ever borrow
money again so hopefully all of that
will help you you keep online with us
and hang on I'll have Kelley pick up
we're gonna put you into Financial Peace
University and try to walk with you guys
while you're walking through this and
we'll also send you a copy of ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
to help with your career choice and
think about what you're going to do
there from the next point forward